183 3 maximum au sol concorde n'est pas
ce que l'on appelle un gros porteur à
peine la moitié du jumbo jet mais au
décollage concors ne peut pas arracher
plus de 180 points donc il dispose de
deux tonnes de carburant pour se mettre
en piste
financé à près de 400 km par heure est
enfin quitter le sol cela il a roulé
plus de trois kilomètres à partir de ce
moment concorde monte à 25 mètres par
seconde jusqu'à 17 18 km d'altitude dans
la cabine de pilotage trois membres
d'équipage à la rampe au tac outre le
pilote et le co pilote derrière devant
sont pas nos instruments ne naviguait à
bord des appareils très complexe
pilotage manuel pilotage automatique
ordinateur de bord de radars météo de
radio haïti note évidemment ce qu'il
faut prévu des télécommunications
arrivé à 55 mille pieds donc en premier
set fut km concorde vols normalement à
plus de 2000 kilomètres à la mecque 2,05
comme des spécialistes
il peut parcourir une distance de 6500
km avec les réserves nécessaires pour se
dérouter en cas de mauvais temps sur
l'aéroport de destination par exemple
donc en gros con corps de l'avion type
pour traverser l'atlantique nord les
passagers ne sont pas très nombreux sens
dans cette cabine de 35 mètres de long
dont tortures de place
inférieur à 2 mètres avec ses quatre
sièges de front intérieur de concours
ressemble à celui de la caravelle cinq
sièges en plus étroits à l'atterrissage
concorde est beaucoup plus léger sens
donnent au maximum et il arrive à près
de 300 kilomètres à l'est il se
contentera de rouler sur deux kilomètres
et demi revient à part sa vitesse sa
puissance et son bruit on gardait un
avion ordinaire donc parfaitement
capables de se conformer aux règles
habituelles de la navigation aérienne
internationale